c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir la mauritanie qui
accusent l'armée malienne de commettre
des crimes récurrent sur son sol contre
des mauritaniens le ministre mauritanien
des affaires étrangères a convoqué
l'ambassadeur du mali dans son pays pour
lui signifier sa vive protestation les
détails de notre correspondante dans la
région sarah sakho dans ce journal nous
irons également a soumis en ukraine où
près de 2000 étudiants majoritairement
d'afrique et d'asie ont évacué la ville
pour fuir les bombardements les détails
dans un instant enfin nous consacrerons
une longue page à la journée
internationale de la femme nous irons au
kenya au niger et en afrique du sud vous
verrez que la femme est plus confrontés
aux difficultés sociales mais qu'elle
s'implique également dans des combats
parfois difficiles avec souvent beaucoup
de succès
on commence donc par la colère des
autorités mauritaniennes le ministre des
affaires étrangères a convoqué
l'ambassadeur du mali dans son pays pour
faire part de son indignation nouakchott
accusent l'armée malienne d'avoir commis
des crimes sur son territoire pour en
parler nous retrouvons sarah sakho notre
correspondante dans la région à sarah
ces accusations sont graves de quoi
s'agit-il exactement
alors en fait la mauritanie accuse donc
l'armée malienne de crimes contre ses
ressortissants en territoire malien il
ya eu cette convocation dont vous avez
parlé meriem il ya également eu ce
communiqué du ministère des affaires
étrangères qui parlent de crime
récurrents perpétré par l'armée malienne
et puis ce matin à nouakchott plusieurs
dizaines de manifestants s'étaient
rassemblés pour protester également
contre ces crimes alors que s'est il
passé exactement pourquoi cette colère
de nouakchott et bien il y a quelques
jours un groupe de personnes on parle
d'une trentaine de personnes ont disparu
ils ont traversé
la mauritanie vers le mali à l'extrême
sud de la mauritanie dans cette zone
frontalière c'est commun cela se passe
tous les jours c'est une frontière très
poreuse donc les gens vont et viennent
et depuis leurs familles sont sans
nouvelles alors beaucoup de zones
d'ombré autour de cette disparition
c'est pas exactement quand cela a lieu
de qu'il s'agit et surtout dans quelles
circonstances ils ont disparu il y à un
député de la zone qui citant des sources
locales a parlé de 15 morts sur un
chiffre qui n'est pas confirmée et donc
dès le lendemain nouakchott a fait part
de sa vive préoccupation de sa vive
inquiétude c'était les mots exacts et ce
mardi et bien ce coup de colère de
nouakchott avec cette convaincante
convocation de l'ambassadeur et ce
communiqué surtout cette grave
accusation contre l'armée malienne alors
il faut rappeler que cette disparition
de mauritaniens côté manière fait suite
à deux autres graves incidents depuis
début janvier donc il y a le wiki ce
week-end samedi deux commerçants
mauritaniens qui ont été blessés par
balles et surtout mi janvier il y à cet
éleveur mauritanien cet éleveur
mauritaniens qui ont été tuées dans la
même zone frontalière côté malien
toujours et cette fois encore et bien la
responsabilité de l'armée malienne avait
été mise en question il y avait même une
délégation mauritanienne qui s'était
rendu à bamako bamako qui avait promis
de faire une enquête enquête qui restés
sans résultat pour le moment le
gouvernement malien n'a d'ailleurs pas
pour l'instant réagi à cette accusation
de son voisin mauritania merci beaucoup
sarah sakho nous suivrons bien
évidemment cette affaire avec vous vous
êtes notre correspondant dans la région
ils sont encore des milliers à être
bloquée en ukraine sans pouvoir fuir les
combats les étudiants africains n'ont
pas tous pu évacuer et rentrer chez eux
a soumis villes ukrainiennes à la
frontière russe d'après kiev les 1700
étudiants étrangers dont de nombreux
africains ont fini par évacuer la ville
laurent berthet cher
bloqué en ukraine depuis le début de la
guerre ces étudiants étrangers attendent
avec impatience leur évacuation les
premiers bus transportant des civils ont
pu quitter la ville de soumis ce mardi
après l'annoncé d'un accord de cessez le
feu entre les russes et les ukrainiens
se rejoignent et un couloir humanitaire
pour la ville de sumidoro s'ouvrir
aujourd'hui cela nous a été
officiellement confirmée par le
ministère russe de la défense aussi plus
de cinq mille civils ont pu quitter la
ville ce mardi dont près de 1700
étudiants étrangers venant
majoritairement d'afrique et d'asie ils
ont été conduits vers la ville de
poltava loin des combats et de la ligne
de front la tanzanie elle a négocié un
autre point de passage pour ses
ressortissants qui ont pu emprunter un
couloir humanitaire vers la ville de
soudja en russie mardi soir un premier
groupe dont des étudiants tanzanien
arrive est sain et sauf alors ambassade
à moscou
c'était trop dangereux pour eux de
quitter la ville sans protection
le cren et la russie nous devons assurer
que nos ressortissants seront conduits à
la frontière et que les soldats russes
les escorteront jusqu'à mort coin
roscoe à 50 kilomètres à peine de la
frontière la ville de soumis été l'une
des premières à être ciblés par
l'offensive russe pris par surprise des
milliers d'étudiants étrangers dont
nombre de nigérians rwandais ghanéens et
tanzanien s'y sont retrouvés pris au
piège
dans las de l'actualité en bref et en
images la création d'un nouvel organe
pour remplacer le conseil supérieur de
la magistrature en tunisie les membres
de cette instance de supervision
judiciaire trempe temporaires ont prêté
serment lundi le conseil supérieur de la
jst ratures avait été dissous par le
président queille saeed suscitant une
vague de critiques en tunisie et à
l'étranger
et puis toujours en tunisie nordine
thierry un chef du parti ennahdha
hospitalisés en état de détention depuis
plus de deux mois a été remis en liberté
ce mardi il fait toutefois l'objet d'une
enquête pour les soupçons de terrorisme
fait l'ubs elle dit un autre cadre du
parti islamiste a également été libérée
au soudan des milliers de manifestants
de nouveau protesté ce mardi à khartoum
contre le pouvoir militaire une
manifestation réprimée à coups de tirs
de grenades lacrymogènes une répression
survenue peu après l'arrestation d'un
opposant selon le parti d'opposition
alliance eu unionistes
et on ouvre cette page consacrée à la
journée internationale de la femme on va
commencer à part une escale au kenya
avec ce constat de l'onu dans les
bidonvilles les femmes sont sur
représentés les raisons sont nombreuses
des revenus irréguliers la nécessité de
passer plus de temps à la maison pour
s'occuper des enfants et donc un manque
de moyens pour payer un logement décent
reportage de nos correspondants bastien
renouil elodie cousin alors comme chaque
matin hélène passent des appels à la
recherche d'un petit boulot elle vit
avec deux de ses enfants et doit
s'occuper seule de sa famille des game
in one fait j'arrive à gagner en train
de revin et un euro 60 à tous mais vous
devez travailler très dur pour ne pas
gagné grand chose sur mon man avec moins
de deux euros par jour impossible de
sortir de la précarité
cela lui suffit à peine à payer son
loyer des sous cette maison me coûte 16
euros avec les notes donc en plus de ça
je ne peux pas me permettre de payer
l'hôpital les frais de scolarité tout le
reste and the school fed aurait vendredi
d'un jeu perd espoir tous mes propres
nairobi concentrent 60% des habitations
informelle du pays dans le bidonville de
kibera il ya sans cesse femmes pour 100
hommes cette organisation communautaire
pointe du doigt la société patriarcale
le kényane ubu phosphates et oui oui
dans cette société en devient mère
jeunes vous êtes un enfant et vous avez
un enfant à partir de 15 ans nous fait
baver man l'homme a le privilège de
pouvoir chercher un travail en en
trouvez moi un homme de 15 ans peut
terminer sa scolarité même si les pères
venue d'une femme elle restera à la
maison il a tellement d'épreuves qui ont
déjà les femmes d'avancé blumann bacs
depuis la constitution de 2010 hommes et
femmes sont censées être égaux mais
douze ans plus tard ces dernières sont
encore très désavantagé selon cette
politicienne en campagne il faut une
représentation plus importante au sein
du pouvoir oui on va l'autre en plus
nous avons beaucoup de ressources à
disposition des politiciens et des
députés il existe des fonds pour les
femmes mais ce qu'ils profitent vraiment
aux femmes sur le terrain quelqu'un doit
se battre et s'assurer que ce qui
appartient aux femmes revient aux femmes
de la communauté locale oman le dernier
rapport du forum économique mondial sur
l'écart entre les femmes et les hommes
indique qu'en l'état actuel des choses
il faudra cent trente huit ans au kenya
pour atteindre la parité entre les sexes
au niger les femmes luttent aussi contre
le djihadisme mais pas sur le champ de
bataille un combat à l'initiative du
réseau national des femmes pour la paix
au niger une association qui intervient
dans les villages pour sensibiliser les
femmes à ce sujet reportage de notre
correspondant à un rôle girard dans le
village de libérer
fatoumata issaka est l'une des
fondatrices du réseau national des
femmes pour la paix aujourd'hui plus de
150 villageoises sont là pour l'écouter
le militaire qui patrouillent et qui
s'occupe de notre sécurité est ce qu'il
sait qu'il y ait un terroriste dans ton
village est ce que le terroriste va se
laisser repérer bien sûr que non c'est
une guerre de ruz
les femmes sont des victimes
privilégiées
dont les zones de conflit la menace
terroriste amène avec elle un risque
plus élevé de viol comme arme de guerre
au niger dont une large partie du
territoire comporte des risques
d'atteinte à leur transmettre les
meilleurs réflexes est un enjeu de
sécurité nationale des aînés nous les
femmes qui sommes à la maison c'est nous
qui voyons tirs entre et qui sort du
village
si dans une maison vide à côté de chez
toi que tu vois quelqu'un qui s'y
installe deux jours par exemple alors
que tu ne le connais pas tu ne connais
pas ses intentions tu dois dire est ton
chef du village qui vit un étranger
des réflexes qui tarde à s'installer
dans les villages concernés pour
fatoumata issaka c'est l'implication de
tout qui influera sur la situation
sécuritaire du pays a appris apa
rolland co responsables locaux qui sont
vecteurs et après en même temps des
rencontres que les nigériennes aimerait
voir se multiplier
mais dans plusieurs zones du pays et
l'insécurité reste trop élevé pour
atteindre une majorité de femmes l'onu
qui accompagne près de 300 associations
au niger dit faire régulièrement des
actions prévues en milieu rural lorsque
le contexte sécuritaire ne le permet pas
malheureusement on ne va pas non plus
mettre en danger la vie des sept
bénéficiaires là où de nos partenaires
et donc nous on préfère par prudence
lorsque la situation ne permet pas
renoncé à pouvoir apporter une aide de
manière ponctuelle qui d'ascq auront
plus venir
avec lorsque la situation se calme en
2020 le gouvernement nigérien s'engager
à intégrer les femmes dont le processus
de paix à l'horizon 2024
pour finir cette success story elle
s'appelle the deal et de l'eau vous elle
est devenue la première institutrice
noire de plongée en apnée mais a
souhaité aux en afrique du sud elle rêve
d'ouvrir l'océan à toutes les
communautés reportage de caroline dumay
et stéphane carstens
on la surnomme la sirène noir sans di
lello vous peu décembre à 34 mètres
pendant quatre minutes sans respirer
bob gainey a while au début j'avais peur
je n'ai pas grandi près de la mer je me
rappelle être resté bloqué une fois 23
mètres à coblence non pas parce que je
ne pouvais pas respirer parce que
j'étais terrifiée à cause de toutes les
histoires que j'ai entendu quand j'étais
enfant
elle est pourtant devenue la première
instructrice noir de plongée en apnée il
y a 20 ans elle n'imaginait même pas que
ce métier exister
ces mères n'ont pas toujours étaient
accessibles à toutes les communautés
l'histoire de notre pays et douloureuse
le monde marin est très nouveau pour les
communautés noires ouais c'est un nouvel
espace à explorer et à connaître minutes
la zone qui les vit désormais au cap
mais elle est originaire de soweto loin
des côtes et quand elle était petite
elle l'italie à la mer qu'une seule fois
ce qui est fou c'est que petit canton se
baigner personne ne se posait vraiment
la question de la vie que j avais sous
l'eau on ne savait pas c'est pour cela
que tout le monde me disait et me
demande toujours pourquoi tu fais des
choses que les blancs font du wild qui
profane c'est parce que sous l'apartheid
des plages comme celle là étaient
réservées aux communautés blanches que
andy les s'est donné pour mission de
faire connaître l'océan à tous les
enfants sud africains est ce que tu t'es
déjà baigner dans la mer
à travers sa fondation baptisée la
sirène noiraude il y enseigne le monde
marin aux enfants de toutes les
communautés pour qu'ils puissent
apprendre à aimer et à protéger a ajouté
je pense qu'il faut sensibiliser tout le
monde ici c'est important si nous
voulons sauver les océans ce tout le
monde doit s'impliquer aux inventaires
les deux sites se dit alors il faut que
tu fasses bien attention donc une tiare
gars on va remettre l'étoile de mer en
place
voilà magnifique
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
l'herbe renishaw
[Musique]